oh yeah I loved getting to know
real-life Tonya Harding she is pretty
much what you see in on interviews is
what you get she was very candid she's
very unapologetic about who she is
and that's fun as an actor to play that
kind of character and she was also very
sweet
I wasn't expecting such a sweet side of
her yeah it's a really exciting time of
year usually you kind of promote the
film and then it comes and goes from
theaters and that part of your life is
over but this one we've been talking
about it since September last year when
we showed it at Toronto so it's nice we
get to keep hanging out with the cast
and crew and it's just nice that anyone
wants to see a film that you work on so
feeling very very yeah grateful lots of
funny things happened we were shooting
in Atlanta and it cast and crew were
amazing everyone was really really fun
and it was an indie film so we didn't
really have the budget for big kick-off
parties or rat pies or whatever so we
would like go to truck stops and it was
very we're really immersing ourselves in
in that kind of world which was really
really fun and unique of Australian and
this is kind of classic Americana
settings which was really cool